what distinguishes indian food is this
magical use of spices
i always loved food and what i perhaps
didn't know is that i had a very good
palate because everything that i was
eating as a child i somehow reported
india is a vast country it's the size of
europe and this variety of food that we
have is what makes indian food indian
not curry i don't think we had such a
word until the british came to india it
stood in their mind for all indian food
how can you take all that food and call
it old curry
if you know nothing about indian food
you take this class just to learn isn't
it fun to find out what they do in other
parts of the world
i'm going to talk about spices
nobody knows spices like we do we are
masters
i will show you how to make indian
breads how to cook a lot of the
vegetables and meats
then we'll make street food i often
serve this as my first course to get the
juices going
it's just delicious
when you cook rice each grain should be
like brothers close to each other but
not stuck to each other i call mustard
seeds the jekyll and height of spices
they can be very spicy and pungent and
hot or if you pop them in hot oil they
turn sweet and nutty
[Music]
eating is such an important part of our
lives it really tells you who you are in
many ways what you eat how you eat it
what your culinary traditions are tells
me a lot about the people of that
country
so if you want to know
what 1.4 billion people are doing with
their lives how they live
come watch this class and you'll get a
good idea
i am madhur jafri
and this is masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
you